So now let's talk about the extension
of PLSA
to derive LDA and to motivate that
we need to talk about some deficiency
of PLSA.
First, it's not really generating model
because we cannot compute the probability
of a new document.
You can see why, and that's because the
pies are needed to generate the
document, but the pis are tied to the
document that we have in the training
data.
So we cannot compute the pis for
future document.
And there was some heuristic.
A work around though.
And Secondly, it has many parameters
and I've asked you to compute how many
parameters exactly there are in PLSA and
you will see there are many
parameters
.
That means the model is very complex
and that also means there are many
local
maximum
and it's prone to
overfitting and that means it's very
hard to also find a good local maximum.
And that really represents global
maximum.
And in terms of explaining future data,
we might find that it would overfit the
training data because of the
complexity of the model.
The model is so flexible to fit the
precisely what the training data looks
like, and then it doesn't allow us to
generalize the model for using other
data.
This, however, is not necessary problem
for text mining because here we are
often only interested in fitting the
training documents that we have.
We are not always interested in
modeling future data, but in other
cases or if we care about generality,
we would worry about this over fitting.
So LDA is proposed to improve that and
it basically to make PLSA a generative
model by imposing a Dirichlet prior on
the model parameters. Dirichlet
is just a special distribution
that we can use to specify prior.
So in this sense, LDA is just a
Bayesian version of PLSA and the
parameters are now much more
regularized.
You will see there are many fewer
parameters.
And you can achieve the same goal as
PLSA for text mining.
It means it can compute the topic
coverage and topic word distributions
as in PLSA.
However, there is no free launch while
the parameters for PLSA  is much
fewer, there were fewer parameters and
in order to compute the topic coverage
and word distributions, we again face
the problem of influence of these
variables because they're not the
parameters of the model.
So the inference part.
Again, face the local Maxima problem.
So essentially they are doing something
very similar, but theoretically LDA is
more elegant way of looking at the
topic modeling problem.
So let's see how we can generalize PLSA
to LDA or extend the PLSA to have LDA
now a full treatment of LDA is beyond
the scope of this course and we just
don't have time to go in depth in
talking about that.
But here I just want to give you a
brief idea about what's the extension and
what it enables.
So this is a picture of LDA.
Now I remove the background model just
for simplicity.
Now in this model, all these parameters
are free to change and we do not impose
any prior, so these word distributions
are now represented as theta i
vectors.
So these word distributions.
So here and the other set of parameters
are pis and we present as a vector
also.
And this is for convenience to
introduce LDA and we have one vector
for each document.
And in this case in theta we have
one vector for each topic.
Now that the difference between LDA and
PLSA is that in LDA we're going to not
allow them to free the change.
Instead, we're going to force them to
be drawn from another distribution.
So more specifically they will be drawn
from 2 Dirichlet distributions
respectively.
The
Dirichlet
distribution is a distribution over
vectors, so it gives us a probability
for a particular choice of a vector.
Take for example pis, right?
So this Dirichlet distribution tell us
which vector of pis is more likely,
and this distribution itself is
controlled by another vector of
parameters of alpha's.
Depending on
alpha's, we can
characterize the distribution in
different ways and with force certain
choices of pi's.
To be more likely than others.
For example, you might favor a choice
of relatively uniform distribution of
all the topics, or you might favor
generating skewed coverage of topics,
and this is controlled by Alpha.
And similar here.
The topic word distributions are drawn
from another Dirichlet distribution
with beta parameters and note that
here Alpha has K parameters
corresponding to our inference on the
k values of pis for a document,
whereas here beta has N values
corresponding to controlling the N
words in our vocabulary.
Now, once we impose these price than
the generation process will be
different an we all start with drawing
pi's from this Dirichlet distribution
and this pi will tell us these
probabilities.
And then we're going to use the pi to
further choose which topic to use, and
this is of course very similar to the
PLSA model.
A similar here we're not going to have
these distributions free.
Instead we can do draw one from the
Dirichlet distribution, and then from
this, then we're going to further
sample a word and the rest is very
similar to the PLSA.
The likelihood function now is more
complicated for LDA, but there's a
close connection between the likelihood
function of LDA and PLSA, so I'm going
to illustrate the difference here.
So in the top you see PLSA.
Likelihood function that you have
already seen before it's copied from
previous slide only that I dropped the
background for simplicity.
So in the LDA formulas you see very
similar things.
First you see the first equation is
essentially the same and this is the
probability of generating a word from
multiple word distributions.
And this formula is a sum of all the
possibilities of generating the word
inside the sum is a product of the
probability of choosing a topic
multiplied by the probability of
observing the world from that topic.
So this is a very important formula as
I have stressed but multiple times and
this is actually the core assumption in
all the topic models and you might see
other topic models that are extensions
of LDA or PLSA and they all rely on this.
So it's very important to understand
this.
And this gives us the probability of
getting a word from a mixture model.
Now next in the probability of a
document we see there is a PLSA
component in the LDA formula.
But the LDA formula would add some
integral here, and that's to explain to
account for the fact that the pis are
not fixed, so they are drawn from
Dirichlet distribution.
And that's shown here.
That's why we have to take the integral
to consider all the possible pi's that
we could possibly draw from this
Dirichlet
distribution.
And similarly, in the likelihood for
the whole collection, we also see
further components added.
Another integral here.
Right, so basically in the LDA we just
added these integrals to account for
the uncertainties and we added of
course the
Dirichlet
distributions to
govern the choice of these parameters,
pi's and theta's.
So this is a likelihood function for
LDA.
Now let's next let's talk about
parameter is making an inference is now
the parameters can be now estimated
using exactly the same approach
maximum likelihood estimator for LDA.
Now you might think about how many
parameters are there in LDA versus PLSA.
You will see there are fewer parameters
in LDA because in this case the only
parameters are alphas and betas.
So we can use the maximum likelihood
estimated to compute that.
Of course it's more complicated because
the form of likelihood functions more
complicated.
But what's also important is not set.
Now.
These parameters that we are interested
in, namely the topics and the coverage,
are no longer parameters in LDA.
In this case we have to use Bayesian
inference or posterior inference to
compute them based on the parameters
Alpha and beta.
Unfortunately, this computation is
intractable, so we generally have to
resort to approximate.
Influence.
And there are many methods are
available for and then.
So you will see them when you use
different toolkits for LDA, or you read
the papers about that these different
extensions of LDA.
Now here we of course can't give in
depth introduction to, but just know
that they are computed based on
Bayesian inference with.
By using the parameters of alphas and
beta.
But algorithmically, actually in the
end, in some algorithm at least, it's
very similar to PLSA an, especially when
we use algorithm called collapsed Gibbs
sampling.
Then the algorithm looks very similar
to the EM algorithm.
So in the end they're doing something
very similar.
So to summarize, our discussion of
probabilistic topic models and these
models provide a general principal way
of mining and analyzing topics in texts
with many applications.
The best basis test setup is to take
tax data as input, and we're going to
output the key topics.
Each topic is characterized by a word
distribution, and we're going to also
output proportions of these topics
covered in each document.
And PLSA is the basic topic model, and
in fact the most basic topic Model.
And this is also often adequate for
most applications.
That's why we spend a lot of time to
explain PLSA in detail.
Now LDA improves over PLSA by imposing
priors.
This has led to theoretically more
appealing models.
However, in practice, LDA and PLSA
intended to give similar performance,
so in practice, PLSA, an LDA, would work
equally well for most tasks.
Here are some suggested readings if you
want to know more about the topic.
First is a nice review of probabilistic
topic models.
The 2nd paper has a discussion about
how to automatically label a topic
model.
Now I've shown some distributions and
they intuitively suggest the topic, but
what exactly is the topic?
Can we use phrases to label the topic
to make it more easy to understand?
And this paper is about the techniques
for doing that.
The third one is empirical comparison
of LDA and PLSA for various tasks.
The conclusion is that they tend to
perform similarly.